you can be good at many things or the
best at one thing and I was like okay
what are these things I'm kind of good
at but I'm not the best at uh acting
yeah Tik Tok I mean I'm not cabbie so
like what can I be the number one best
at and I was in the top 50 of shorts
creaders I was like okay I can be the
top shorts Creator let's go for it most
of this game is about self-awareness for
such a young dude for you to be able to
read that book tap in and then have the
humility and self- awareness to say I'm
not the best actor or I'm not sure I
could be or maybe but or I'm not even
the best at Tik Tok even though I've got
some action I can be the best at this
YouTube shorts thing I think that will
work for a lot of people who are
listening right now attention is the
number one asset vayer Nation how are
you excited for a fresh new uh non-
throwback non-edited from some sort of
keynote episode here live in Hudson
yards at the office uh really Dynamic
individual here that I think
is going to be able to give some
insights and inspiration to a lot of
people that are on their journey of
really creating content around a passion
or trying to achieve attention in a
modern uh digital media landscape and so
when this opportunity arised I was like
this this is actually the right time
especially as I'm writing a new book
called day trading attention that will
come out next year um I think this uh
this fits well and will really help uh
add some color commentary and so with
without further Ado my friend why don't
you tell the Boehner Nation who you are
and uh and how you describe yourself and
then I'll go into my series of questions
yeah GRE to meet you Gary great to meet
you too my friend I am Alan chicken chow
I am a creator with the mission to unite
a universal audience through laughter
and storytelling and I am the number one
YouTube shorts Creator uh in the world
actually um I got started making videos
as a way to connect with my family when
I went to college my mom and dad they
moved to a little town in West Virginia
where they had no friends or family so I
started making videos just as a way to
make my mom laugh gone from my mom to
like 40 million followers across
platforms 30 billion views we we crossed
recently and a full you know business
with full-time employees so I'm really
grateful for this journey and now I'm
here talking to you let's take it back
so you grew up where I grew up in Dallas
Texas okay and so when you went to
school your parents moved uh yes yeah
when I went to college and so because of
that that before that point you grew up
consuming content at scale on the
Internet or no yeah I did I I watched a
lot of content especially Vine rip Vine
miss the vine days and I remember you
know I had a period when I was depressed
in high school and I remember I did this
challenge called 100 days of Happiness
challenge where I took a photo of
something that made me happy every
single day and 3 40% of those were just
screenshots of vines cuz they were the
only thing that made me happy during a
depressed period so that's something I
think about a lot when creating like
happy which which V creators stood out
for you during that era do you remember
during that era um you know what I
actually still back in that day I liked
uh uh I actually liked like the the top
viners like King Batch and Amanda cery
those types and they stuck around so um
I think they were great but I really
love like the the trends like the thing
that was great about Vine was you
couldn't really upload videos that were
like taken from your phone you had to
like shoot it on your phone it was like
like the oh my gosh I'm trying to think
like uh of of Vine Trends it'll come to
me but like like just like the really
anain like um yeah the stuff that Rudy
and Jerome jar and all the mallis and
all those guys were doing yeah exactly
exactly and the ones that are just like
normal people I mean I really do think
in a lot of ways that vine was the
preview to the Tik Tok world we live in
today um and and really changed the
landscape okay so you start making these
videos for your mom yeah and what what
what is the next step in the journey
what from Mom to 40 million followers
across platform what was the first sign
that this was going to be a little bit
more than just Mom yeah so um the so my
video started to go viral like here and
there as I was so you made the video for
Mom but you knew to post it everywhere
with it giving maybe a chance of
something happening is that how your
mind thought about it yeah well I I had
a Tik Tok page and my mom was my only
father and I would just post them so
that she would watch them but then but
you had a sense that maybe something
would happen with them right sure yeah
yeah yeah definitely it's not like you
made something that would be a video
that you would only text your mom you
would make it with Mom as audience of
mine with a conscious or subconscious
understanding that maybe one would hit
and you would take it from there yes
exactly yeah and by the way the reason I
just brought that up and I apologize
this is where I'm trying to make it huge
for the audience like that is a really
smart way to think about it I really do
think too many people go into the game
which is now the game everyone's living
which is like let me get famous on
social media exactly you know with the
intent of I need to be famous I need to
make money I think if you go in with the
intent of I'm G to make videos that
might go but I'm making it for this
purpose whether it's for your mom or
it's your favorite hobby or you're
making it for a group of you're like
think about all the text message group
threads right now with six or seven
people in it where people just making
each other laugh that that could in
theory obviously with a couple of tweaks
and less inside jokes or maybe more
inside jokes be something people could
post on all platforms now because we're
living through the Tik Tock ification of
every platform so that was your journey
for Mom but comma maybe it might hit
exactly yeah yeah and that way you can
keep that genuine purpose around that I
still have in creating my videos my
mom's still my target audience but um
yeah but but more people can see it and
um one big thing happened where I was
like I was getting like traction online
like you know get maybe I think like
10,000 20,000 followers and I went to
volunteer at a school in Indonesia and I
had done acting for film and TV and I
was very proud of it I was on like gra
anatomy and some shows and I went to
these kids and I wanted them to watch my
episodes and they had no idea what like
ABC was or gra Anatomy but they were
like so excitedly consuming my videos
and I was like wow this is the future
this is the future of media like like
glob content is the future and at in one
moment I can post a video right now and
reach 40 million people that's actually
crazy there's no barrier between me and
those people all over the world I I
remember seeing that moment and being
like wow okay I think that I should take
this serious this is not a platform to
get me to TV this is TV yeah yeah
exactly yep mhm I I you know I I really
genuinely I wrote the first book I wrote
crush it ah yeah that came came out in
2009 basically says that premise right
and so like hearing you go when was that
moment um this was around
2020 Great so like thinking about you
going through that moment in 2020 around
something that I've like really believed
to be true in since 2005 really six
since YouTube 2007 I it's really fun
because I still like what when I just
heard you say that I'm like man my brain
while you were telling that story was
like man we're still that early where
that's not just common wisdom right yeah
that you even though you were in acting
paying attention to vine for you even
just three years ago it's like whoa wait
a minute this is the platform not the
stepping stone to the platform I think
is a really important call out I think a
lot of people don't realize the podcast
their YouTube show their Tik Tok account
their LinkedIn for B2B like being huge
on
LinkedIn let's say a top 50 followed
person on LinkedIn is a bigger platform
than writing for the Wall Street Journal
or being on CNBC and I think people
continue to struggle with that knowledge
and I think we're starting to get to
that realization yeah yeah that's so
true like and there now there's so many
Platforms in it it's so interesting you
bring up that tiktock ification of the
different platforms that's right so the
next step in my journey was um moving to
YouTube and actually my brother who's
here with me now he created my YouTube
channel and he uploaded all of my
original Tik toks yeah onto YouTube
because he heard from you that basically
on Tik Tok at the time you couldn't
search so like if friends like wanted to
search for your Tik toks they couldn't
find it but YouTube was powered by
Google so they could search up Alan
chicken chow mom funny video and they
could find it right so we started
uploading on there and then I read an
article that shorts was being beta
tested in India and I was like okay so I
went and I hashtag all the videos shorts
one of them went really viral uh and had
like 100,000 views whereas all the other
ones had like 10 and it came from 99%
unknown source and I was like oh this is
YouTube's way of telling me this is
YouTube shorts before it even had a
metric of how to tell me YouTube shorts
this is going to be huge so I started to
focus all in on shorts because um I like
I think that YouTube has created some of
the biggest businesses and the biggest
St stars and has a very healthy economy
with AdSense um and yeah so our we
shifted our Focus over there and now
we're the no one shorts Creator in the
world and of course it took a lot of
work between that like a lot of like
like what like I I read this book called
essentialism which said you can be the
best at one thing or I'm sorry yeah you
can be good at many things or the best
at one thing and I was like okay what
are these things I'm kind of good at but
I'm not the best at uh acting yeah Tik
Tok I mean I'm not cabbie so like what
can I be the number one best at and it
was in the top 50 of shorts creators I
was like okay I can be the top shorts
Creator let's go for it and so I just
cut away it was actually about saying no
to a lot of stuff cut away all these
like distracting opportunities in order
to focus all in and then you know the
normal working hard like get up work
every day be consistent get up early
post every day doesn't matter like if
you're tired or sick like do it let's go
back to that I remember I remember when
my friend
Travis decided to go fulltime as the CEO
of uber so he was a
co-founder and they hired a CEO because
it was actually Uber cab which is the
original name of uber was a side project
of Garrett Camp who was the founder of
stumble upon which was a very early
internet Discovery platform that was
huge and Travis who was who had a
Napster competitor as a kid at UCLA and
later had a big company and was a really
talented guy who was an investor when I
met him and we were investing in
startups together they joined up they
did Uber cab they hired an incredibly
talented young man named Ryan Graves to
be CEO and then Travis kind of
recognized wait this might be big and
decided to become full-time CEO and I
remember in this like three-month period
because we talked a lot during that time
um I like hit him up about like two
Investments and like one other thing and
like a conference and like another thing
and every time he was like and I didn't
understand it actually at first he he
said no no Gary like I only do Uber now
I was like okay and then I hit him up
again and he's like no no like I have to
give 100% of my effort to Uber now and
like I'm the other side of the pillow
I've got 47 things like I'll do this
with you right now which is content and
the garyb of it all my next meeting is a
vayer x meeting that really matters the
next one after that is a Vayner is a
vriends meeting I'll call AJ on uh my
way to a nonprofit board that I'm a part
of called pencil promise the Gallas
tonight I have a call with AJ about
Vayner Sports in between literally just
my afternoon today yeah has five
different things I'm involved in and
that's what makes me tick and I enjoy
that I think what's important about that
is I want everybody to listen real
quick most of this game is about
self-awareness for such a young dude for
you to be able to read that book tap in
and then have the humility and
self-awareness to say I'm not the best
actor or I'm not sure I could be or
maybe but or I'm not even the best at
Tik Tok even though got some action I
can be the best at this YouTube shorts
thing I think that will work for a lot
of people who are listening right now I
think on the flip side you get inspired
by that and you're not self-aware if
15-year-old me heard that that would
have either been a moment where I was
like oh I want to be like him and I
would have tried to force myself into
being something I wasn't or 15-year-old
me would realize that's cool there's
different ways to do that I think for
everybody who's listening I do believe
that in the extremes of success that
I've at now 47 years old have looked at
I think the two people on this podcast
right now represent it all in chaos or
all in one thing because the chaos keeps
people like me happy which makes the
whole thing go I think sometimes people
are caught in the middle they do two or
three things and they don't realize they
should do 17 or one yeah and that's the
one takeaway I hope that provided some
people some value so okay so you go all
in how long did you go into that like in
the cave crazy like [__] saying no to
everything full full full full full like
you wouldn't even be here right now if
you were in that zone how long did that
zone last until now okay I love that for
like a year year and a half yeah um do
you feel like you're on the other side
of that craziness and you're ready to
like okay I've hit that goal I've get
The Branding of that yes I built out
more of a team um um you know so
actually to that question where are you
at right now like how are you thinking
about that next step yeah so I I love
what you said and and I think you can
bounce between being essentialist and an
all inist or or Explorer curiosity
framework uh a business development a
tasting things by the way I do that too
yeah even for all like even in my
craziness of doing 100 things there are
moments I mean be friends I was gone for
a year yeah and like to launch it so I
do think you can bounce yes yeah and so
now I'm I'm in that bouncing stage where
we're we got The Branding we we achieved
our goal we are the number one shorts
cre in the world so like right now for
me it's all about elevation like how do
we take the content elev is number one
based on the way you're saying it the
most followed or the most views short
View and do you feel attachment to that
like do you worry that now you'll go
discover things that you'll quote
unquote get past um or you feel like
you've got that you're good you
recognize that if you're not in the lab
18 hours a day on it inevitably somebody
else is doing that right now and they
will pass you yeah I think I'm I think
I'm I I'm in the works is it a little
bit both yeah we'll see yeah no it's an
interesting question I I think where I'm
going for the broader audience is I
think sometimes we as humans attach to
something without realizing that that
could actually be your downfall yeah
like I'm so empathetic and I actually
loved that you answered it the way you
did which is like it's hard to give that
up it's fun to you brought up four times
in like five I get it yeah I do this
stuff all the time times whatever it is
I think it becomes a jail for a lot of
creators or creatives whether it's an
arbitrary number a blue check yeah as
high as you've gotten which is insane
that's an insane to think because I'm a
very big believer in YouTube shorts and
what I love about shorts is I think it's
much more longtail than other platforms
yeah like you achieving this level of
abew that has longtail value three years
from now that Tik Tok doesn't that
Instagram doesn't yeah because because
YouTube is the second most searched
platform in the world besides Google you
will get that long tail whereas even
though Tik Tok search is growing it just
it's just different and so that that's
pretty powerful but I do think it's
interesting to think about like will you
now go six months exploring yeah Will
some kid in you know in
Argentina go six months in the lab and
pass you and what does that feel like
you know Charlie demilio had to go
through that because she was so
identified like that and I think many
people have to go through that yeah yeah
and thankfully I I I am I feel like a
whole person that's not like super
attached to my work in that I feel so
identified by these things and so I
think I'm okay whatever happens in the
future and I'm really passionate about
what I'm doing next which is building a
long form series out on on my YouTube
channel it's a it's a show called
Allen's Universe go watch it if you
haven't seen it it's a high school love
story um based on love friendships and
growing up and it's a 9 10 minute series
that's completely done without talking
so we're trying to take the cabie
concept that works on Tik Tok and prove
that Global content is a future and can
work and Reach people across the world
when you're doing that are you
scratching your
acting yeah bug yeah exactly and to that
out of pure curiosity do you
envision the Netflix of the world do you
envision feature films like do you
envision doubling down on your core
acting skills sure I think that's a
definitely that you want that I think
that's definitely a possibility are you
getting distracted by the businesses
that can be built by being an influencer
at this scale call it the Mr Beast and
the Logan Paul and K like are you
thinking about consumer products yeah um
I think I think I'm really open to what
is in store next like because we're just
coming off of building to be at the top
and so I'm in exploratory period where
I'm not opposed to Consumer products I'm
not opposed to say hosting a show or
like creating a show with we just I just
had a meeting with the CW yesterday like
just being really open to what's next
being in the mindset of maybe and then
once going through that deciding what's
yes and no yeah yeah yeah like like you
said like be being being very open to
all these different things because you
don't know what's going to hit and I
think I think it's brilliant I I I think
the world is atrocious at maybe yeah
people walk into everything so yes and
noed doubt and I used to say like don't
be a no person be a yes person I
realized wait a minute I'm not a yes
person I'm a Maybe person ah I go into
everything with maybe and then I make a
decision yeah I think if you're overtly
no you're cynical and you've already
lost I think if you're blindly yes
you're often delusional and not
practical and I've come to realize it's
actually maybe that is the powerful
world for all of us yeah yeah yeah and
and it it it can change with the
different eras in your life as well well
that's inevitably the power of maybe
yeah exactly right like if you know how
old are you I'm 26 W so you know when
it's as epic as being 26 and really
having the world as your oyster you know
you're going to you're you're going to
go through an incredible chapter here ah
yeah 10 years from today you're still
going to be shockingly young and you'll
be 10 years of learnings experiences
success and failures both personally and
professionally and to your point you'll
be met with new opportunities that you
might be met with today that in 10 years
maybe if you lean with maybe may end up
being a no that today is a yes or vice
versa that is absolutely right yeah and
one thing that I am certain on is my Glo
my mission like what I want in general
which is to unite a universal audience
through laughter and
story that I think that is such a
brilliant contemporary point of view in
understanding how distribution works mhm
yeah that's achievable yeah especially
with what's coming next the fact that
every one of your videos will have ai
voice and lipsyncing completely done in
two to three years and you will have
videos speaking everything from German
to farsy to Russian to every other
language like that's the next step for
all of us yeah one of the remarkable
advancements in AI already is is
transcribing and dubbing it's it's
insane to me that I'm going to go to
Turkey and go to Warsaw and go to Paris
and tons of people are going to run up
to me in five years and talk to me in a
language I can't speak because I've been
speaking to them in their native tongue
that's bananas that's crazy crazy and
then of course I start thinking about
okay well then the ear pods are going to
have translation and all the AI and just
like we're all just going to be talking
to each other which is you know
Wonderful because I think communication
and dialogue is the only way we can fix
a lot of our problems yeah yeah yeah
yeah the the uh the changes that AI are
going to make to content is going to be
huge I was go ahead no please I was just
going to say it was part of an
announcement with YouTube where uh
they're they announced alloud which
allows you to dub with one click it's
crazy crazy like and it's just the
beginning so see how it's going exactly
right before we get out of here knowing
that you thought about like being on the
podcast what have we not touched on yet
that we want to touch on obviously I
want everybody to check out your channel
and your handle so let's push that real
quick how do they people find you uh yes
it's Alan chicken chow on YouTube Tik
Tok Instagram everything spell that out
for everybody who's like me and can't
spell a l a n c h i k i n c h o w and
that's my full real legal name and and
what else did we not touch on that you
think you want to touch on to this
audience yeah I just I want to say again
that I think Global content is the
future like what you said about AI like
what cabie proved and if you look at the
top most viewed like Tik tokers top all
of them don't talk I think that the
future is global content the future is
global in general not just
content yeah the world is so connected
and that's what I'm passionate about
that's what I think is the next step the
the next stage of um creators about what
about while I've got you and no and I
have a good sense of who's listening to
this what about the Fortune 500 CMOS and
CEOs that listen to this literally the
biggest brands in the world you know how
should they be thinking about engaging
with creators and influencers at your
size what do they get wrong what do they
underestimate you know and kind of like
what do you you know even giving you a
second of who would you like to collab
with or what kind of things are you
looking to collab with if if you're even
looking to collab yeah I think I think
still to this day a lot of the
traditional Industries they still don't
understand the level of influence that
influencers have uh I was part of a beta
shopping program on YouTube where we
would tag products and it was a beta
test and I would tag these products I
have this red flannel I wear all the
time I'm not wearing it right now but um
I we would we would tag it and um it
would suddenly go unavailable all the
time and me and my assistant we kept on
giving feedback to the team like hey
there's something wrong with the button
it's unavailable but you probably also
understood that it was selling yes it's
not like it's again back to the book
back then people like you might have
been Cal and nice to YouTube or Google
but you knew the [__] was [__]
selling no that's what I was going to
say their response was no it's not
unavailable because every button Works
you're selling the product out but you
knew that right I didn't know really
genuinely I didn't know I mean I saw the
amount of clicks that we were getting
but I didn't know that we were like
selling out this flannel like this is
crazy I mean to me it's like to your
point I get whether you're being
self-deprecating or humble I get why
Fortune 500 CEOs don't know to your
point yeah but I think all of you in the
trenches know yeah we're living it we
know uhhuh yeah so I think that in
influencers that the amount of influence
that we have is it's insane like the the
amount of traffic that we draft to sell
[__] on the internet in that format to
sell [__] if there was a draft like a
sports draft and there was 50
celebrities on television and movie and
film Netflix included from Hollywood and
50 top creators from YouTube and Tik Tok
and I was one of the teams drafting I
wouldn't draft a single person from
Hollywood until every Creator and
influencer was off the board true yeah
that's how big the Gap actually is and
I'm talking any celebrity MH take your
top 15 actresses yeah you know now an
actress or actor who's also killing it
on social then I may you know you give
me a keev a Ryan Reynolds a Kevin Hart
then I'm then I have to think it but
even with those people I just Rihanna
even with them if we're really talking
top 50 Creator influencer top 50 primary
Hollywood I'm I'm taking the first 50 on
the left side prior yeah it's just it's
just that big of a gap of influence at
this point yes the cat is out of the B
yeah um but yeah I would love to work
with Disney I want to build the next
Disney that's like my my dream and
Legacy and so and do you think about
that the way I think about it with be
friends from uh animation and character
based or do you think it more like the
Disney Channel stuff that content that
we see more of like Hannah Montana yeah
I think I think I'm I think about it in
terms of Storytelling I want to build
the the strongest like characters and
and um stories on my channel that can
build a legacy that surpasses me good
for you my friend thank you for being on
the show thank you for inspiring people
and thank you for entertaining and I I
do believe that in a world of a lot of
content that strikes fear into people
and unhappiness I think it's incredibly
important to people that are Shining
Light on Love and Happiness smiling and
positivity and I appreciate you being a
contributor and that was a very primary
reason why I wanted to have you on the
podcast and I hope that everybody who's
listening gets to discover this young
man's content and uh hope everybody has
a wonderful
day